Seitenklappen, Seitenklappenklappen mit geradeaus.
Beim Seitenklappen, also in verschiedenen Könnenklappen, nach wie vor, ist es so, wenn
wir eine Seite einklappen, dann Brems, das den Schirm, also erinnert euch mal
hoch anlegen, alles, was klappt Brems, in dem Fall Brems, das direkte Seite ziemlich ab,
und es würde eigentlich eine Bewegung nach rechts resultieren.
Also die Schirm würde gerne Dynamik nach rechts herum aufbauen, wir wollen das nicht.
Wir wollen, wir wollen mit derという Klamppür in smartest
welchenittens.
Und dann wollen wir das mit der Gegenbremse verlangsamen. Warum denn mit der Gegenbremse erkläre ich euch sofort.
In der Theorie ist es so, ihr müsst das auch angreuzen, wenn die Frage kommt bei der Flugpraxis.
Den Seitenklapper stabilisieren, müsst ihr zusätzlich das Körpergewicht auf diese offene Seite legen und damit ein bisschen weniger Bremsen.
Aber in der Praxis ist es so, bei einem 50%-Klapper funktioniert das vielleicht noch.
Weil 60-70% was ihr dann wirklich für uns eher das Problem ist, funktioniert das nicht mehr.
Das heißt, ihr habt so viel Last am rechten, Ertraggurt weg. Das schafft ihr gar nicht auf die linke Seite rüberzlegen.
Und es ist nicht einmal förnlich. Wenn wir das Gewicht fallen lassen auf die geklappte Seite,
dann wird der Tragegurt zu allererst auf der Ehe, wenn er wieder belastet.
Das bedeutet mir verheben den Schämen viel eher zum Wiederöffnen.
Also, fallen lassen, das könnt ihr euch auch merken für die Fliegerei.
Das Körpergewicht fallen lassen ist immer gut, ihr belastet immer genau die Seite, die gerade belastet werden muss.
Deshalb machen wir das auch.
Gut, wie können wir das Ganze fliegen?
Richtig ist natürlich, dass wir probieren diese 40-50% Fläche einzklappen.
Und das schaffen wir, indem wir zu allererst einmal auf der Klappseite die Bremse an den Druckknopf fixieren.
Oder magnet, wie man hier, das ist egal.
Oder ihr lasst dir einfach los, aber ja nicht in der Hand da halten.
Weil wenn wir jetzt die A-Gurten ziehen und die Bremse in der Hand haben, die Bremse vielleicht das Mühe mit,
dann weißt ihr nicht so recht, was soll er tun, soll er einklappen, oder soll er wieder öffnen.
Da die Bremse weg, fixieren sie am besten, dann macht sie am wenigsten Chaos.
Die andere Bremse bleibt ungewickelt, aber ganz oben am Steg in der Hand.
Da könnt ihr euch aber, wenn ihr wollt, ein bisschen nach Tragegurt abstützen,
dass die Hand da nicht irgendwo ins Ue weghaut.
Also so leicht am Tragegurt abstützen.
Nie am Tragegurt festhalten, sondern immer nur so abstützen.
Gut, dann kommt da vielleicht auch ein bisschen nach vorne.
Es ist wichtig, dass ihr auf jeden Fall über die Leidensschlässer kommt, alle Alleine.
Das heißt, auch diese hohen Anleghilfe.
Die müsst ihr auch mitnehmen.
Also alle Alleine, die ihr habt, mit nehmen Oberhalb der Leidensschlässer so packen,
mit den kleinen Fingern nach oben und Zeitgefinger und Daumen umfassen das Leidensschluss,
so Oberhalb des Leidensschluss.
Und dann könnt ihr ziehen, am Anfang zieht ihr mal etwas langsam,
dann die Alleine fixieren, weil so schaut es dir euch grad wieder auf.
Ziehen und dort wo er das Grad hat, könnt ihr euch am Hauptrag festhalten.
Und jetzt vorsichtig mit der linken Bremse arbeiten.
Ganz Gefühl, Fluch zu suchen, gerade aus Fluch zu suchen.
Und dann mit dem, gerade aus Fluch,
den 13.000, den Fingern.
Das ist so nicht unbedingt so,
dass ihr die Bremse zieht und dann dort behalten könnt,
sondern da müsst ihr vielleicht ein bisschen arbeiten.
Drum ist diese Fluch zu suchen, aber so wichtig,
am fixen Punkt im Gelände zum Schirm schauen,
nach vorne schauen.
Eier, jetzt fliege ich gerade aus, wunderbar.
Jetzt kommt das Kommande von mir klapperlösen.
Okay, dann geht die rechte Hand als die Klappseite einfach mal nach oben.
Die linke Hand sucht weiter den gerade ausflug.
Bis der Klapper draußen ist.
Und dann kann die gegen Bremse einfach nach oben freigegeben werden.
Auf Parkheimfall einfach alles loslassen,
weil wenn der Klapper drin ist, dann drehen wir nach rechts auf die geklappte Seite ab.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Also darum, die gegenseite einfach stabilisieren,
bis der Klapper draußen ist.
Wenn der jetzt nicht von alleine rausgeht,
dann holen wir uns die Bremse, nehmen die Bremse und pumpen einmal.
Zack!
Pay!
Immer noch gerade ausflug.
Wie sollisieren?
Schauen, wo geht's denn?
Alles klar.
Schirm ist immer noch nicht offen.
21, 22, 22.
Fuck, ich geb ihm noch mal ein, oder?
Dann ist es offen.
Und wenn ich noch mal ein Buch da,
aber immer in so zwei, drei Sekunden abstehen.
Und wenn das der Fall ist,
ist es hier im Hof nicht.
Dann können wir mit beiden Händen wieder waren.
Beziehungsweise mit der Aures Hand ganz hoch.
Jetzt!
Warum mit der gegenbremse so vorsichtig arbeiten?
Wir haben einen sehr, sehr kurzen Steuerweg.
Wir haben 50% Fläche, wo wir gefällt.
Das heißt, wir haben nur noch 50% Fläche, die fliegt.
Darin hat euch Flächenbelastung steigt enorm an.
Und mit der Flächenbelastung steigt auch der Steupunkt an.
Das bedeutet, wir haben den Steupunkt viel eher erreicht.
Also Steuerweg ist deutlich kürzer geworden.
Und der Druck im Schirm.
Also gerade noch auf der Seite, auf der Bremse, der ist enorm hoch.
Das heißt, der auch der Steuerdruck ist höher geworden.
Also muss wirklich feinfühlig fliegen,
ganz feinfühlig den gerade Ausdruck suchen.
Und das Ganze natürlich ein paar mal trainieren.
Einmal links, einmal rechts,
dass wir sich dann nicht zu fest verbessieren.
Okay.
Wenn wir jetzt zu wenig Fläche rein bekommen haben beim Seitenklapper,
dann dürfen wir dann noch mal dran gehen.
Also lasst dann los, sag ich ja, lasst noch mal los,
gehen noch mal dran.
Dann müssen wir versuchen, ein bisschen aggressiver zu ziehen.
Also wir müssen 50% doll immer hingekommen.
Wir dürfen auch mal in der Schulung 60% fliegen.
Oder 70% gehen nachdem, wenn wir mal gut den Höhe haben.
Aber wichtig ist, wenn wir jetzt wirklich zu wenig haben.
Und es ist so, wie 40% dann sag ich zu euch,
tierbislanggressiver.
Also dann dürfen wir dann mal hingehen.
Ein bisschen aggressiver ziehen.
Vielleicht zieht er dann noch ein bisschen tiefer.
Und der Schirm legt sich auch vom Klappen her viel besser nach hinten weg.
Und dann wieder auf genau das gleiche vorsichtig Gegenstück her.
Einfach nur so weit, dass er gerade ausfiegt
und den geradeaus überhalten, bis sich das Kommandergeber klappen lassen.
Und dann als wieder nichts zuerst den Klappen lösen
und dann die Bremse, wenn der Schirm auf ist.
Einfach das zum Klappen.
Einmal rechts, einmal links, immer dran denken.
Auf der Klappenseite vorher die Bremse fixieren.
Weil das nicht macht.
Und ich glaube, so runter zieht er wird sehen.
Der Schirm wird sich nicht sehr gut klappen lassen.
Da braucht er wirklich die Bremse frei,
also gar nicht mit in der Hand behalten.
Gut, okay.